[Music]
to start off here are some adjectives
that I associate with Rachmaninoff music
a crucial ingredient is the common
arpeggio let's take that to a lower
register and we're going to make it
slightly more complex by adding some
more harmonic information
[Music]
now let's get familiar with this
galloping dotted rhythm
[Music]
sometimes the accent will be on the
front end of the grouping now let's add
chromatic neighbor tones to each of
these courts for a harmonic progression
let's choose one that has a common tone
in the bass
[Music]
the more augmented chords the better
[Music]
let's take chords in triplets and the
more massive the chords the better
now let's take the Quranic scale and
nudge them between arpeggios and other
passages have multiple layers of sound
and bring out inner lines at key moments
[Music]
how the lines interact with each other
as in dialogue
open up the music to grandiose
expressive and soaring melodies
[Music]
here's a passage grouped evenly together
now let's make it two against three and
now six against seven here's a cadence
with a secondary dominant chord voice it
in a way that's richer and more open
make use of a wider register of the
keyboard keep in mind that many of the
chords are colored with extensions with
exception to the resolving chord in this
way we're oftentimes only a few notes
away from a jazzier sound include
sparkling passages in the upper register
[Music]
create drama by building up momentum and
energy
and the more iterations of the ending
the better
and now here's happy birthday in the
style of sergei rachmaninoff
[Music]
you
[Music]
you